Speaker 1: All right. Let's keep going and get
caught up on a whole bunch of other stuff. There
is a new filing from Donald Trump's attorneys
related to the search warrant raid served on Mar
a Lago, the documents that he had in his house,
etc., etc.. And if you look through the legal
argument, the filing from Donald Trump's lawyers,
they make a shocking admission in the filing and
it has to do with some quotes. Quotation marks
are effectively a shocking admission here.
David, how is that possible? How is it possible
that quotation marks are a shocking admission?
Well, the use of these quotation marks exposed
the level of desperation that these lawyers
are now exhibiting. And it has to do with
quotation marks around the word classified.
In a number of spots. In this legal filing,
Trump's lawyers put quotes around the word
classified when talking about classified
documents, and they decry in the filing that
the government has unilaterally determined that
these are so-called classified documents. Think
about that. Think about the level of desperation
that you have reached when your legal filing
attacks. The fact that the government and the
government alone has determined documents are
classified, and you call that classification into
question with quotation marks. Who else determines
the classification of documents? Who else gets to
decide? And when you are experiencing, it's one of
two such brain rot. Or such desperation that in
order to assemble what is an attempted defense
of your client's actions, you have to put in
quotes the word classified and act as though it's
illegitimate or wrong that yeah, the government
did. When we talk about classified documents,
we're talking about the government. What
does Apple get to decide? What are classified
documents? No. Corporations can have trade
secrets. Sure. But of course, it's the government
that has decided what is a classified document.
And here the entire legal filing is based around
the idea. And I'm not going to spend a lot of time
on this. It's just to kind of let you know where
things stand. The legal filing is based on the
idea of trivializing classified information. Now,
remember, at first it was the FBI planted
this stuff. This wasn't even stuff Trump had,
and then it was, well, Trump had declassified
all of the stuff. And then, of course, that fell
apart because it just doesn't work that way. Even
William Barr, Trump's own former attorney general,
said, you can't just go declassified and
everything's declassified. It doesn't work
that way. Then we determined that, in fact, the
classification status of many of these documents
is not relevant to the statutes under which Donald
Trump is being investigated. But put that aside,
they don't seem to care about that now. They've
moved on to trivializing the concept of something
being classified and whether the classifier is
legitimate when the classifier is obviously the
government. This is obviously chaos all created
by Donald Trump's actions, but they are adding
to the chaos Trump's lawyers added to the chaos by
requesting a special master. And then now they're
telling the judge, you got to stop this chaos.
Well, this is chaos of your own creation. These
are absolutely and completely total clowns.
That, by the way, the word that should be in
quotes is lawyers, not classified. And we'll see
whether this works out or whether it goes anywhere